what would you say to people who are
more of the reclusive artist who come up
with beautiful story ideas and rich
characters beautiful scenes but they're
not in the mood to be on camera or the
show person but they know they almost
have one person from the project has to
be what would you say to them you mean
if they wanted you Kickstarter or just
you don't wanna know or IndieGoGo either
one or whatever what even if it's not
crowdfunding but they should I actually
can answer because I've seen a couple of
very good examples you know where where
they have an avatar basically I've seen
a couple of presentations where there
was an animated character or the act or
you know or the actress you know making
the whole presentation you know or just
a group of people and they've been very
very effective you know and in fact
sometimes even more effective than the
person themselves you know sort of
showing their own ego sometimes the
camera
you